thank you all for coming today this is a
wonderful
celebrate the career of our
leaks it all men I want to get petition
thanks to our all-star lineup of
speakers have come from around the
country and around the world here and
also Tehran breaker and his staff for in
MCD be for organizing this event my name
is Dan de Mayo I'm a professor of
genetics at Yale I first met said in
1973 I was a yell college senior with a
rather dreary prospect of going to
medical school and I took a course
that's it taught along with some other
junior faculty Joan Stites and bill
summers and Charles riding I'm molecular
genetics I learned about suppressor
trnas and knots and codons and about
messenger RNA the genetic code and about
bacteriophage lambda and it literally
changed my life I decided to become
molecular biologists it's now 40 years
later I'm still doing it so thank you
Sid for that I only talked to Sid once
at that time I went to pick up I final
exam and Sid was in his office and he
was surprised because I thanked him and
he was surprised because if students
usually came to him only to complain
about their grades so I did think you
were a little tough on question four but
other than that I appreciate that if you
walk down the hall down the street to
the Yale campus you'll pass this
building it looks like a castle that's
Ozma marine laboratories and in the
archway there's a little plaque bronze
plaque that says this is where Joshua
Ladenburg discovered that bacteria can
transfer their genes I haven't seen a
plaque like that yet inclined biology
tower for Sid but we need to have one
and we will get one up to recognize Sid
and his fantastic discovery that RNA can
have enzymatic activity and work for
which he is obviously a word of the
Nobel Prize in 1989 it's interesting
parallel that when oswald avery
discovered DNA was the genetic material
everyone spent years trying to prove him
wrong and show that protein did the work
and when sid identified RNA SP he spent
years trying to show that protein did
the work before he discovered it was RNA
and so i think perhaps the listen to
that is proteins are overrated and so
it's great that we can recognize that we
all the science for various reasons
basically we want to understand how the
world works but it's
very unusual that we can make a
discovery that really changes how we
view life and that that's what SIDS
experience experiments were and so I
thinks it really belongs in the pantheon
of yell scientists along with later Berg
and with Benjamin silliman who give the
first lectures in science at Yale or
josiah willard gibbs who discovered
thermodynamics or the great
paleontologists OC Marsh who discovered
Stegosaurus and Triceratops in fact if
you walk down the street the other
direction you can look at the original
bones not of marsh or Gibbs but of
Triceratops and Stegosaurus so I know
you're eager not to hear me but to talk
here are distinguished lecturers and so
I like to just give a couple of ground
rules please turn off your cell phones
and beepers I will leave mine on so I
can beep after half an hour to tell
people that they should be finishing up
if we have time at the end of each talk
will have questions but if not we'll
move on directly and they'll be plenty
of time for questions private
conversations during the breaks so our
first speaker is Matthew meselson who is
a Dudley Cabot professor of the National
Sciences at Harvard is a great title I
think Matt is known to probably
everybody in the room for the famous
bezels install experiment in 1958 that
showed that DNA replication was
semi-conservative unlike Republicans
they're not so my conservative anymore
but but Matt's contributions really
extend beyond this single experiment he
discovered messenger RNA three years
later he carry out important discoveries
on messenger on recombination DNA repair
and restriction enzymes and during the
Vietnam era he led the charge to make
sure the United States never use
biological weapons so I think we he
deserves quite a bit of credit and
thanks for that in the late 1960s he had
a new postdoctoral fellow a promising
young scientist named Sidney Altman and
so I think we can also thank Matt for
helping Sid become the scientists that
he is so the title of Matt's talk is sex
is necessary
I chose a title to which there'd be no
objection so when I used to visit Yale
to talk to Sydney sometimes I always I
also talked with another source of
wisdom even Hutchison so one time I was
talking to even I think the year before
he died in his lab still working but
bent over and with evil and it was very
hard to talk for very long because you
run out of things to ask him because he
knows about everything but for some
reason i asked him evil and why do you
think sex exists and he said well you
must know about the deloitte rotifers
fine never heard of them this was a long
time ago but I thought they might be
interesting to look at these little
animals and so here's what they look
like some of them there are a few
hundred identified morpho species and
and they have some unusual properties
they were first described by Lou Ann
Hawkins 1724 and he found them by adding
water to some of the dry dust from the
gutter rain gutter of his house and
Delft and saw that after a while little
animals came out of this dry dust and
that's because they survived desiccation
has do very few other animals there are
little complicated little things there
have about the same number of cells as
senior have dittus elegans and they have
a lot of origins and muscle and even a
tiny ganglion and here's what they look
like when they're all dried up you can
keep them for years dried up and just
add water and they come back to life and
can continue reproducing before i get
into the subject
whether they reproduce sexually or not I
just want to mention some interesting
other things about them there are
mentally resistant to radiation as
compared with Monica not rotifers which
are a different kind of rotifer which
cannot be desiccated or to C elegans or
to nearly anything you can put hundreds
of double-strand breaks into their
genome and they fix them all up but it's
not because the DNA doesn't even get
broken at the rate in which it gets
broken in radiation sensitive things the
number of double-strand breaks you get
in DNA in anything bacteria HeLa cells
is always approximately point 005
double-strand breaks per megabase of DNA
/ grave radiation it's always the same
and buffer it's different the reason
it's always the same in things with
compact nucleoid zor nuclei is that what
breaks the DNA is hydroxyl radicals and
direct compton interaction of photons
with the backbone hydroxyl radicals come
from water in buffer there's water all
over around the DNA and the short-range
hydroxyl radicals made by the radiation
can get over to the backbone and break
it but if you compact all the DNA
there's not much water in there and so
the number of the production of hydroxyl
radicals is greatly reduced within that
volume and the main cause of breakage is
pure physics Compton scattering so
that's why all DNA in nucleotides and
nuclei has about equally radiosensitive
to to breakage the reason why they're so
radiation sensitive then is not because
their DNA knows how not to get broken
it's because the repair system doesn't
get damaged until very high doses
something is preventing now this is
protein carbonylation which is caused by
hydroxyl radicals something is
preventing the formation of hydroxyl it
could be catalase because hydroxyl
radicals mainly are produced from
hydrogen peroxide in this system but
that hasn't been followed up the reason
I mentioned it is this
this is an interesting system I'm not
going to do it I tried a little bit to
do it but I'm going to stop teaching
pretty soon don't tell any Dean's but
there's old free radical hypothesis for
what drives the aging process so this
great protection against free radicals
is in young Deloitte's they age just
like other things with a death rate that
doubles every three days the gompertz
rule and the question would be when
they're really aging do they still have
this protection if they do is one
reasonably critical experiments saying
that the free radical hypothesis is
wrong the other result doesn't have any
firm conclusion so these are useful
animals because of that now they make
eggs mitotically meiosis has never been
observed males if they've been observed
at been observed only once in 1932 by a
very good rotifer biologist but he was
so surprised that he found them because
even then in 1932 there was a couple
hundred years of people not seeing any
males and it was the only claim and they
were found in a place where very few
people would look under the ice and a
frozen lake and Denmark where the water
was teeming with deloitte rotifers and
he claims he saw a few males other than
that no one's ever seen any males or at
least reported it so eggs are made and
from primary oocytes you see the oocytes
here inside and ovary there are two
ovaries that shows one and then pretty
soon although it's a different kind of
microscopy the one of these primary
oocytes decides to become an egg and
here you see both ovaries in each one is
developing egg and then the egg is
wiggled out through the rear end of the
animal so they're pursued a paper
appeared in 2013 the first genomic
sequence and not a complete sequence but
a lot of
folds of Adelaide rotifer and looking at
these scaffolds it's clear that there
were no long scaffolds that had
homologous copies which means that there
cannot be any homologous chromosome
pairs which you would think would mean
that chromosomes can't pair in meiosis
and maybe you would think that therefore
there can't be any meiosis well they
don't teach it anymore but in old
genetics courses we learned about tina
through the evening primrose in which
there's 14 chromosomes seven from each
parent all very nice looking in somatic
cells but in meiosis they all form one
giant ring of 14 chromosomes tip to tip
and when anaphase happens all the
chromosomes that came from the pollen
grain go to one poll and all the
chromosomes that come from the ovule go
to the other pole and so you pull apart
just what you came in with the entire
haploid genome goes cruising through
generation after generation there's no
crossing over except maybe at the tips
and there may be gene conversion but no
one's done any real sequencing with
these very interesting plants it should
be done but it's not being done it
hasn't been done anyway so and the
evolution of these is very interesting
it seems that the precursors of these
full ring formers or cases in which you
do get chromosomes to peer but only at
the tips as though they don't want to
have crossing over and no synaptonemal
complex except maybe at the tips i'll
come back to what that could mean so we
wondered in our work was already in
process ish maybe this paper saying that
there were no homologous pairs of
chromosomes did not necessarily mean
there's no meiosis maybe there could be
evening primrose kind of meiosis so and
we finish this work and published it in
June and so now I'm going to tell you
about that so we're going to do a test
for six the test for sex is this let's
say we have all these people they're all
diploid and I want to know if you
reproduce sexually so I look at some
particular locus there are two copies
the alleles in each individual and what
if I should find that one end
vidual has alleles a and B and the other
individual has allele C and a exactly
the same a well they must have had a
recent common ancestor now with you guys
I know it's not by transmission of DNA
fragments like in bacterial
transformation already I know that must
mean that those two people are either
brothers or descendants from a very
recent cross if I do this at many
different lo sai and I find it with
these two individuals at every locus
then for sure it's not bacterial
transformation which would be here and
there but not everywhere so that's what
we're going to do we're going to look at
now we need to look at individuals who
belong to the same species in this room
that's not a problem but with rotifers
how do you tell what it's the same
species now what we found was so
surprising it was done initially by Anna
signarama she was a student and Leo bus
here and she did it this kind of
experiment with a completely other thing
blaka zones and she got this astonishing
result and I didn't believe it and she
left a lab and J her re isolated all the
back of all the deltoids and I'm going
to tell you about and repeated the work
and got exactly the same result I still
didn't believe it well I believed it but
I knew that the reviewers would hate it
and so I asked Eugene Gladish of who's
now doing amazing things with ripping
and nipping if he would Ricci quence
some of the anyway they all agreed we re
isolated from single eggs got the same
results as I'm not going to describe so
how do you get a species well one way to
find things that are closely related as
look at their mitochondria and when you
do that as had been done a lot by other
people we didn't look at that many but
we collected daylight rotifers it looked
the same under the microscope and then
we sequenced their [ __ ] one genes and
their mitochondria and informed clades
and we picked the clade with six
individuals in it one individual was
from Long Island another from one's
whole another from the highway between
witzel in cambridge one from Harvard
Yard one from milano italy
these things when they're dry float in
the air and if you put on a dish of
water a couple days later you'll find
these little guys so maybe it came over
by air who knows but anyway it's member
of this clade one from Milano and then
one from the bank of the Charles River
six different isolates so now what we
did first was to sequence the same ten
kilobase region in each of these six
isolates and there are two alleles this
is we can think of it as like a diploid
it is a diploid for all intents and
purposes so there'll be two copies of
this ten kilobase region which contains
the histone genes and a bunch of other
genes there'll be two copies of that
segment in each animal and so all
together there are 12 different
sequences here and this is just a
genogram whatever you call it and the
amazing thing you see here is that one
allele from wood from Long Island is
identical all 10 kb to an allele from
Woods Hole no difference at all and here
one allele from the Long Island again
the Long Island is involved in this is
almost the same as an allele from the
charles river bank the only difference
is two substitutions near each other
which might be one mutational event
because mutations tend to occur in class
anyway this is very close illegal
sharing so we looked at each of four
regions in every case we found the same
thing the one from Long Island has one
of its alleles in common with the one
from Woods Hole and its other allele in
common with the one from the banks of
the Charles River well since these four
regions we believe are not linked that's
like saying that this is from a crops
it's not from little pieces of DNA
independently coming in and there's a
mathematical argument then I could make
extremely unlikely there could be
independent events so in colors two
things first of all
this if you do a cross here's a simple
cross there we're looking at one locus
and there are four different illegals
here four colors and the progeny there
are four kinds of progeny you can get
out of it and you'll notice that each
one shares one of its alleles with one
other and its other allele with another
other and that will be true for any one
of them so that pattern which is what we
see is what you expect for a cross but
more than that it's the same pattern the
one that shares with two others is
always the one from Long Island that's
not expected because if there's
independent assortment Allah Mendel then
it should be one or the other region
that shares with the two others because
you've fragmented you randomly assorted
the different chromosomes or even more
than that if there's crossing over you
randomly and sort of the chunks from the
crossovers so now I won't drag you
through this but in a factor in a cross
between two hybrids this is the old
punnett square there's 16 possible
progeny all equally likely and then
we're selecting three individuals from
this pool and we find this funny
relationship and the number of different
sets of three that you can pull from 16
different kinds of things is that thing
with all the factorial signs and if
there are 16 things this is from a cross
just a two-factor cross there's 16 so
they're 816 different ways of pulling
three individuals from that group if
there were three or four independently
of sorting low side there be even more
ways and the bottom line is that it's
exceedingly unlikely that we would get
this pattern if there was independent
assortment and we could talk about this
later but I'd be wasting time right now
here's what in a thorough evening
primrose does as I already mentioned
semmes as chromosomes which look all
separate in my my toes
I'll make this big green ring and I
Kinesis in meiosis and the gametes that
come out or either pure mother are pure
father and so that could explain how you
could buy DNA sequencing not find any
pairs of homologous chromosomes because
there's all kinds of translocations and
stuff as I say no one's done any
sequencing but there are other ways
famous ancient ways of showing that
there are lots of translocations there
are no pairs of homologous chromosomes
and these so-called permanent
heterozygous plants that's what evening
primrose oil a bunch of other plants
that do this to not just evening
primroses Derringer shows the separate
chromosomes nicely and one of these big
rings in a different kind of plant try
Scandia now question their billions and
zillions of dim light rotifers out there
including there must be huge numbers of
this particular clade out there we only
sampled a few how is it we were so lucky
to find the recent descendants from a
cross and that's why nature and science
and Current Biology all rejected this
paper but then I read a paper by Michael
inches lab in daphnia ordinary daphnia
sometimes mates Daphne up you Lex mates
with another kind of a daphnia if a
female daphnia meets with that other
fuel ex meets with that alien other kind
of daphnia the outcome is total
sterility it's called what's got my
marvelous name forget I'll think of it
very humorous name anyway Mike in his
lab wondered after this infliction of
the loss of sex on ordinarily
psychically sexual daphnia Pollux how
long do those completely asexual
lineages hang around and one is thinking
of Muller's ratchet it will take
thousands of years and then finally die
out no they died out within about 20
years why their hypothesis is this
the population is loaded with
deleterious recessive presentations but
that's okay they're heterozygous so
they're all covered by wild-type now we
turn off sex but gene conversion happens
it turns out that a rate much higher and
not just in daphnia measured in a
different lab not mike and the same has
been found in a rabid opsys say we
didn't know that gene conversion
happened so often because if you do
ordinary crosses the markers are so far
apart if there's a little gene
conversion inside you don't see it it
turns out that the frequency of gene
conversion in daphnia anyway is such
that the chance that a single nucleotide
will fall under a conversion track is a
hundred thousand times greater than that
site will be mutated by substitution
it's a huge frequency the same in a
rabid opsys the same in several other
things were good experiments the
mutation accumulation experiments have
been done so this is happening at such a
fierce rate that it makes your recessive
deleterious mutations homozygous or else
it gets rid of them by making them both
well duh but half the time you've become
homozygous so pretty soon you're dead
weaker and weaker and then you're dead
unless you have cross so now the delayed
rotifers generally don't reproduce
sexually but it's plausible that if they
die very soon if they haven't recently
experienced a round of sex that the
majority of the population that's out
there have recently experienced around
the sex so at least that convinced the
editors of genetics and I got published
no why should they be so weird what is
it about evening primroses and deli
rotifers well human populations and
bears and snakes markers telling jokes
about snakes they move around in groups
so you have a big gene pool and you can
keep on making different combinations
and adapting to changed environment and
so on but del I rotifers land one and
then reproduce asexually make
a monoculture there's nobody to have sex
with except yourself so there's no point
in really having sex so the same with
the evening primrose it's extremely
weedy a single seed falls into a patch
of disturbed vegetation and Wow within a
couple years it's taken over the whole
field and then it dies out so these
kinds of individuals with it's very
strange life history our thought and
this is all hand waving of course to
need reproductive assurance that is the
first time out you got to make it or
nothing will happen so that means that
if you have a pretty good genome which
is heterozygous of course you don't want
to start recombining you've already got
a good genome don't mess it up leave it
the way it was so you don't want
crossing over and that might be as I say
this is hand waving why we know that
with the evening primroses the earliest
ancestors didn't make rings they had
ordinary buildings except they didn't
look ordinary they look like this
pairing only at the tips in other words
it's like saying we don't like crossing
over because that would mess up this
otherwise highly adapter genome I'm
getting dirty looks so I'll stop there
but what needs to be done next is full
genome sequencing of these particular
rotifer isolates which will probably pay
some company to do but thank you very
much
title says sex is necessary to talk seem
to say no when we need a microphone
testify I didn't say how often okay
different for different though it's not
original okay goodly this is just magnet
but the evening primrose thing was that
it would gave off these monsters right
these odd things that was what got
visitors the beautiful flower okay what
accounts for that if there's no what's
the current explanation for how those
extreme variants pop up if there's no
crossing over in the Primrose you're
thinking of Hugo devries well this guy's
what else is there to solve my genetics
he knows his genetics uh he was studying
mitotic drive is that right no anyway um
the question was how does it happen the
Rings break down once in a while and all
hell breaks loose also there are many
different they're called Renner
complexes complete haploid genomes and
once it usually selfs but once in awhile
it out crosses has to have sex once in a
while to restore heterozygosity i would
say so bible that true of the rotor
first to do you think we have is this
genetic evidence i think the reason no
one sees males is most people get
rotifers either from a monoculture well
they're not going to bother having sex
then probably like monica not rotifers
you have to have two different strains
that he produce particular proteins that
trigger meiosis in each other that's
known for manga not rotifers and the
other i forgot what i was going to say
but it was interesting but i forgot
happens to me all the time oh yes why
people don't find meals we collect
editors typically from Moss if you look
at Moss there's one deloitte sitting
here and one here and one there that's
not a situation where you expect
anything like this pheromone signal you
need a liquid culture where things can
diffuse molecules can diffuse and a high
density and almost nobody looks at
cultures that have likely to have had
different species forming a liquid
culture at high density this lake in
Denmark in the middle of the winter
apparently or may if that guy was right
been such a case the five main timer is
very destruction sensitive is it
possible that that coil twisted DNA
takes the bases a little further apart
from each other so that the timing
diamonds are not formed in the radiation
we do know by measurement that the
efficiency of double-strand breaks is
the same in deloitte rotifers as it is
in everything else and so if the
structure of the genie is a little
different it doesn't matter to the
radiation sensitivity but it don't is
the same but it might not matter in the
formation of the timer information of
the time between two adjacent timings
like matter to various things if it
exists but it doesn't matter to
frequency of getting double strand
breaks because we measured it it's the
same as in everything that is the odd
double strand breaks the only cause of
death a double double strand breaks the
only cause of lethality in after the
radiation that's a good question in the
yeast almost certainly in bacteria
almost certainly because you can measure
it very easily and yeast you have to do
it in g1 in haploids because otherwise
you'll get repair in bacteria there are
no diploid if you have bacteria with
only one nucleus and so in those systems
it can be easily shown
each break is lethal it's harder to do
with a diploid because it gets repaired
you don't know which breaks daybreak
remain breaks yes so the answer is from
bacteria and yeast yes but otherwise I
can't say so uh sex we reduces the
reproductive capability of species by a
factor of 2 reduces the reproductive
capability because only half full cost
yeah to fold cost so most of the
explanations for why we have sex if you
do a mathematic quantitatively you don't
come up to a factor it's a tough
sledding you have to overcome a two-fold
disadvantage anybody done the math on
you know with the frequency of there are
about 20 different published hypotheses
which actually can be grouped under a
few headings for why sex exists so this
is embarrassing for two reasons one is
you have to have a magnitude to overcome
the two full cost of six and certain
other costs like what if you don't even
find a mate or the cost of finding a
mate over the mates fight it's all so I
or eat each other so that's one problem
the other problem is the embarrassment
of so many different hypotheses so it's
Darwin said the reason why it takes two
individuals to produce one is yet hidden
in darkness which is a little progress
since then but
I heard on science friday i think it's
ira flatow that there's very few perhaps
only two or three organisms that enjoy
sex do you have a comment on that we
could take a poll but do you know
whether the ball would be with human
beings and there among the grouped and
enjoy sex as I understand it anyway
interesting question I'd just be on my
if anyone here has an answer to that I
don't know I'd like to find the
reference to that you mean they look
pained well that's true devore at
harvard who's an anthropologist showed
us a movie once with lions copulated and
the male line was looking but it off
like this not at all pleased from what i
remember it's not only was not only not
only humans but giraffes and elephants
were two other than enjoy sex I have a
little strange you know the difficult
given her anatomy much would you export
this fellow up
music